alors bienvenue à tous d'abord c'est
très heureux de vous accueillir dans ce
lieu que vous connaissez bien
mais avec une équipe que vous connaissez
- là dimanche dernier les électeurs de
droite se sont fortement mobilisés pour
demander un nouveau souffle à droite et
nous voulons porter cet espoir de
renouvellement qui tire les leçons des
erreurs du passé et qui fait surtout la
place aux nouveaux talents
maintenant la brad se tourner vers
l'avenir
elle le fait avec une équipe qui est
d'abord une équipe jeune 43 ans de
moyenne d'âge des nouveaux visages et
des élus qui en sont pour un grand
nombre
alors prenez mandat c'est évidemment une
équipe paritaire vous avez deux absentes
et surtout une équipe qui a la volonté
de travailler ensemble
vous allez autour de moi des gens qui
viennent du gaullisme mais aussi du
centrisme vous avez des libéraux mais
vous avez aussi la droite sociale et ce
sont surtout des gens qui ont envie de
construire ensemble
pour certains ils ont soutenu des
personnalités qui sont différentes par
le passé et ils sont aujourd'hui surtout
tous déterminé à laisser ses divisions
derrière nous la liste est donc la
suivante avec les excuses de virginie
calmels ce et de sophie primas qui n'ont
pas pu se libérer elles étaient toutes
les deux soit retenu au sénat soit sur
des déplacements première
vice-présidente et donc avec le titre
statutaire de vice présidente déléguée
virginie calmels ce 2ème vice président
monsieur guillaume pelletier troisième
vice président monsieur damien abad
j'ai également souhaité sur le poste
statutaire de secrétaire général demande
et annie genevard de s'occuper de cette
mission
secrétaire général délégué à la
communication geoffroy didier avec
ensuite une équipe aux côtés de annie de
six secrétaires généraux adjoints
julien aubert valérie boyer mathieu
darnaud fabien di filippo virginie duby
muller et sophie primas enfin pour
porter la parole de notre famille
politique j'ai demandé à lydia guirous
ce hal gill plâtré et à laurence sailly
de s'en occuper
par ailleurs je vous signale que je
proposerai au prochain bureau politique
à daniel fasquelle de rester trésorier
cette équipe incarne une nouvelle droite
une droite rassembler une droite
populaire et surtout et c'est comme ça
que je le veux une droite quel courage
de dire et qui aura surtout le courage
de faire voilà merci à tous je vous
laisse maintenant les découvrir ça me
semble de loin le plus utile et donc
passer du temps avec eux ça vous
permettra de découvrir les uns et les
autres
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]